I always feel like people with
Incredible Talent on some level know it
they know it subliminally they just
somehow know it and I was looking back
at your story and realized that you got
these scholarships to these amazing
college in Berkeley School of Music well
I think like right like in in high
school it was
um
I was informed because I was very poor
that like a way for me to get to college
would be a scholarship and they were
like you sing well like if you wanted to
go this route that you'd be able to have
if you get to a certain point like if
you chair like make a certain chair or
whatever because it was like Opera like
I was saying that kind of classical
stuff so and I absolutely 100 hated it
um I I love listening to it now
um but yeah when you're 16 and you want
to sing I want to dance with somebody uh
this is not yeah it's not this and who
are you listening to at this point you
were like a huge Alanis Morissette fan
I'm a huge everything fan like Nirvana
like Whitney Rosemary Clooney like Reba
Max I live across the board Just Like
Music I love Metallica I love I love a
lot of different things so hence why I
cover a lot of different styles of music
but
um it was just it was told to me if I if
I worked on ice and I achieved a certain
status that I could get scholarships
like rides like because I couldn't
afford it there was no way I could
afford that um so um I did work my tail
off and um I achieved that to where I
could it was like UT or UNT Berkeley was
something I was very interested in as
well and to get into Berkeley School of
Music on a on a on a ride you know to
get a scholarship that's a big deal well
it's a correction I just knew there's a
correction there it's I didn't actually
ever end up applying I just had heard
via my music program that like once you
achieve this you could get that so I
didn't I'm not impressed at all yeah I'm
sorry no I didn't and I think your whole
career has been a sham I didn't know
this podcast is over no I didn't
actually ever reply because I ended up I
was working at like Six Flags Over Texas
Real Story doing the singing and dancing
the shows there and um this girl
randomly yes was crying and like her
roommate bailed on her to move to LA and
so instead of going to college like a
teacher's kid my mom is a teacher
instead of doing that route I was like
you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna eat
ramen noodle and sit on a mattress then
sleep on a mattress in this Random House
in La and just try and make it work you
did odd jobs I have lit like named
something and I've probably done it
Hitman Hitman
still time still time and don't think I
haven't thought about it
I have a list
every one of the records everyone in the
record business has a list
um okay so but I heard that you were a
rep for like Red Bull energy drinks I
was yeah I was a rep yeah it was cool
you got paid like a good amount of money
it was like I feel like 12 now just to
like drive around their truck with their
gas money and going like lakes and be
like hey I want some free product and
then you just get to hang with these
people and then you can hang out with
them afterwards it's literally my job I
mean that's it's great to be cute and 20
right like or I was in 20. I did that
now at my age yeah
hi kids
I have treats are you gonna be frowned
upon yeah
here they're like yeah you're cute go do
that it was like a great job yeah
um so you're working these different uh
jobs and I know that you were a waitress
at like a comedy club hyenas okay do you
remember like bad tippers did you ever
in those do you ever Channel those
people in your mind and think I am now
one of the biggest stars in the world
and which you could go back in time and
tell that person who left you 35 cents I
was an idiot just like look when you're
poor and like you literally have gone
without electricity or like food
um when someone tries to walk out on
their bills I just remember this and
since it happened they left and I chased
these individuals which are grown men
can I was like 18 and chase them out to
the car about to shut the door put my
boot in the door oh my God I literally I
don't know what you can say on this show
but I said you forgot
something
I was like I was like because you can
say that on the show and by the way
that's your next song that
but no I think it's still time to get
into chemistry but it's really dangerous
I shouldn't have done it my my boss was
angry at me for doing it because he was
like you can get like it's a dark
parking lot or whatever and I was like
you would have made they make you cover
the ticket if somebody does that to you
you have to cover it I couldn't afford
that it was worth the risk of getting
the beat out of me I was like oh
that's I mean I I completely understand
in that period of your life too there's
something about it nothing you are bold
and brave right what's that what is it
got nothing you got nothing to lose yeah
so you go for it yeah um but no anyone
listening don't do that